the chancellor and prime minister are
trying to convince us that Britain faces
problems that are nothing to do with
them
that the mini budget which imposed a
Tory mortgage premium put pensions in
Peril and trashed our reputation around
the world was all just a bad dream it's
their Bobby Ewing strategy
Downing Street as Dallas old cast
members return as if nothing had
happened
ability and everyone knows it is long
past time that this series was canceled
and the problem for the British people
is this this is not a dream this is the
everyday nightmare of Tory Britain
Mr Speaker the conservatives would have
us believe that they are not responsible
for the last 12 years of failure
in doing so they take the British people
for Falls
millions are already worried sick about
how to make ends meet and are now facing
the added stress of higher mortgage
payments the prospect of home ownership
becoming more and more remote and rents
going through the roof
what does this mean
family holiday is canceled savings
depleted
hopes for the future replaced by
sleepless nights
and all of this on top of the fact that
the average worker is earning less today
than when the Tories came to power 12
years ago the government has presided
over the biggest wage squeeze in
centuries
this was a crisis made in Downing Street
and it is ordinary working people who
are paying the price
now Mr Speaker as I was coming into
Westminster today I read a timely
warning from the police about
pickpockets in the area they warn you
may have an idea of what a pickpocket
looks like but they're far less likely
to stand out in a crowd than you think
they may work in teams to just try and
distract the Target and one of their
tactics is where a thief will appear to
be over friendly while pickpocketing you
now I must report that in the last hour
the conservatives have picked the
pockets of purses and wallets of the
entire country
has deployed a round of stealth taxes
taking billions of pounds from ordinary
working people
a conservative double whammy that sees
Frozen tax thresholds and double-digit
inflation erodes the real value of
people's wages